ça ne vous est jamais arrivé dans les
dîners ou quand vous faites des
rencontre que la première chose qu'on
vous demande c'est tu fais quoi dans la
vie où tu as fait quoi comme école alors
en fonction de ce que vous allez
répondre sciences po hec
c'est ap coiffure bts comptable on va
vous mettre dans une case on va se
focaliser sur une orientation que vous
avez fait à 18 ans alors que ce choix
finalement n'était pas forcément le
vôtre ça pouvait être le choix d'un
parent le résultat de votre scolarité de
votre milieu social parfois vous êtes
sur un chemin qui ne vous appartient pas
moi j'adorerais qu'on me demande dans
ces dîners mais au fait qui es tu à quoi
rêve tu où je mintues commandant stu
avec la vie
j'adorerais qu'on me demande qu'est ce
qui te met en joie et j'adorerais
pouvoir répondre moi je m'appelle
valérie et j'ai 35 ans je suis vivante
je suis moi et je peux vous dire que
c'est déjà un boulot à plein temps
je ne sais rien faire d'autre que d'être
viscéralement moi même ce que l'on fait
ne nous définit pas vraiment est ce que
vous savez que le mot métier vient de
l'expression ministère mystérieux
notre être au monde notre mission de vie
est un mystère et on a une vie pour
l'explorer alors mon métier c'est ça
alors non je ne cours pas dans les rues
quoique non mon métier c'est plutôt
d'être un peu comme un chat d'être libre
autonome à la fois ancré et en mouvement
mon métier c'est d'être de développer
mon sixième sens de guetter les signes
du moment présent comme on guette une
proie d'être adaptable de toujours
retomber sur mes pattes et ce métier ça
s'appelle free life 2 qui vient donc de
l'expression free life vie libre c'est
un terme qui a été inventé par rené
durringer de l'observatoire des
nouvelles tendances et qui a vu derrière
les free leifer un véritable phénomène
de société
il ya neuf ans donc j'ai décidé d'être
une free life 2
j'ai eu envie j'ai voulu vivre en accord
avec mes valeurs
avec mon rythme avec ma sensibilité avec
ma créativité
j'ai voulu libérer mes identités
multiples je voulais me connecter avec
ma nature profonde parce que la vocation
du free leifer c'est de persévérer dans
son être le fameux connaît tous de
spinoza
du coup j'ai accepté cet appel j'ai
accepté cet appel intérieur vers la
grande aventure d'être moins alors vous
allez me dire dis donc valérie mais
c'est pas un peu égocentrique comme le
choix c'est pas un peu risqué alors oui
c'est assez risqué au début votre
famille vos proches vos amis ne vous
comprennent pas forcément il ne vous
soutiennent pas en fait vous les sortez
un peu de leur zone de confort et puis
surtout il peut être il projette en vous
leur propre peur pourtant il n'ya rien
de plus altruiste que d'être soi même
il n'y a pas de meilleure manière
d'apprendre à vivre ensemble que d'abord
d'apprendre à vivre avec soi
alors pour devenir une free life 2 je me
suis affranchi de mon milieu de mon
éducation
je me suis affranchi de ma religion
je me suis affranchi des partis
politiques des institutions des dogmes
je me suis affranchi de ce que la
société industrielle et l'école
attendait de moi et paradoxalement je
n'ai jamais autant était spirituelle et
citoyenne j'ai voulu suivre le lapin
blanc comme dans alice au pays des
merveilles je voulais être suffisamment
folle pour provoquer l'avenir je voulais
que la réalité et du génie je ne voulais
plus perdre ma vie à la gagner alors je
suis donc devenu auteur de ma vie au
sens propre comme au sens figuré
je suis passé de petits soldats du
journalisme à créatrice de mon quotidien
j'écris alors donc j'ai confort j'ai
cofondé un magazine j'ai été conseillère
politique
j'écris donc des chroniques personnel du
crabe à la première personne
j'essaie série documentaire sur la
société post carbone peu importe en fait
pourquoi vouloir à tout prix
se mettre dans une case c'est l'ego qui
cherchent une identité l'important en
fait c'est que mon élan professionnels
soient alignés avec mon élan de vie mon
élan à moi c'est de cartographier le
monde de demain à l'aune de mon regard
nous mon expérience de ma sensibilité
d'optimistes j'explore la vie et je
danse avec je raconte les jugements
individuels et collectifs
ce que je suis se confond avec ce que je
fais je ressens j'explore je vois et je
le raconte
et ce pour être toujours cohérentes
enfin j'essaie donc le jeu j e devient
un jeu j e
un voyage initiatique un roman
d'aventurés une histoire où tout devient
possible
une occasion de tenter le tout pour le
tout de se jeter corps et âme dans la
vie j'ai toujours hâte de connaître la
suite suis gourmande de rencontre j'aime
quand les événements font chaînes comme
dans un film
tous les chemins sont bons du moment que
c'est moi qui les ai choisis
l'important c'est de savourer ce chemin
mon but c'est de vivre la vie avec
panache décrire ma propre histoire du
moment que c'est moins qui remporte le
premier rôle mais alors vous allez me
demander comment on devient auteur de sa
vie alors tout d'abord en se simplifiant
la vie
si la vie est comme un jeu les règles
peuvent être simples donc déjà essayé
autant que faire ce peu d'être davantage
dans l'être que l'avoir essayé
d'embrasser la vie de l'accueillir comme
elle vient avec humidité être ancrée
dans le moment présent à bord du train
dit d'une free life 2 les lieux les
événements s'enchaînent au gré du hasard
et du moment présent
tout est là d'ailleurs en anglais
present ça veut dire un cadeau donc moi
je suis riche en fait de mes rencontres
des gens qui m'entourent de ma
créativité de mon imagination
je suis riche des ressources qui sont à
l'intérieur de main le ma capacité à
toujours trouver des solutions
alors j'ai aussi un autre instrument
pour devenir auteur de ma vie c'est mon
rapport au temps j'ai ce qu'on appelle
une slow life
donc j'ai insuffle du temps par exemple
à mon intériorité jung-su feu du temps
on mon rapport aux autres dans ma
manière de m'investir dans la vie de la
cité
et puis j'apprends à me connecter à mes
sens à mon intuition
j'essaye d'être un petit peu moins dans
mon cerveau gauche a le cerveau gauche
qui est plus le cerveau de l'analyse du
rationnel pour passer à mon cerveau
droit le cerveau droit c'est le côté
beaucoup plus instinctif plus animal
plus intuitif et puis j'apprends aussi
j'essaye d'être d'être bienveillante
car c'est en donnant qu'on reçoit et
surtout j'essaye de ne pas confondre
autonomie et autosuffisance ce que le
jeu est toujours ancré dans un nous et
puis dans cette aventure
je cherche aussi à renouer comme je peux
avec cette petite fille cette petite
fille cette petite fille c'est moi bon
comme vous pouvez voir il y avait déjà
un peu une tentative d' enfermement dans
la société
donc cette petite fille elle a très vite
été rattrapé par le système éducatif par
un statut de première de classe ce qui
est parfois une maudite chance pourquoi
parce que mon ego au fur et à mesure de
mon parcours scolaire et de mes études
c'est un peu glissé dans cette identité
j'avais l'illusion qu'en étant première
de classe d'un peut-être que je me
ferais davantage aimé et pourtant cette
identité dans le fond elle m'a un peu
éloigné de moi même un peu éloigné de
cette petite fille qui est qui dansait à
la fin des repas de famille qui
écrivaient qu'ils révèlent qu'ils créent
et qui voulaient qui rêvait d'être une
artiste comme dans la chanson et du coup
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à
désapprendre pour réapprendre
être moins à être cette petite fille au
fur et à mesure de cette reconversion à
soi je n'ai jamais été seule je ne suis
jamais seul gg j'ai rencontré énormément
énormément de gens les libertaires des
affranchis des nomades des auteurs de
leur propre légende des joueurs de poker
des intellectuels des artistes des
musiciens des magiciens dérape des
réparateur de machines à laver le linge
que ce soit la boulangère le chauffeur
de taxi que ce soit un message
publicitaire
un livre qui me tombe sous la main tout
est porteur d'un message
tout est source d'inspiration tous nous
nourrit je suis la somme de toutes ces
personnes que j'ai rencontrées elles
m'ont indiqué toutes sortes d'outils
toutes sortes de pratiques pour
apprendre à être vivante pour apprendre
à déconnecter du mental a lâché un peu
cette première de classe
parmi ces outils j'ai testé la
communication non violente
j'ai testé le tantra j'ai testé la
permaculture humaine j'ai testé la danse
des cinq rythme j'ai testé le flamenco
j'ai testé le yoga la méditation tous
ces outils m'ont appris à équilibrer ma
part féminine ma part masculine aligner
mon corps mon coeur et mon esprit a
identifié mais colère mais incohérences
et contradictions à faire la paix en
moins pour faire la paix avec les autres
mais l'outil qui pour moi reste le
meilleur
la meilleure école el tango
pourquoi le tango et surtout dans ce
cadre de vivre ensemble parce que le
tango c'est une danse qui se danse à
deux et donc à travers ce couple il ya
un effet miroir et cette danse elle est
là pour nous apprendre à savoir qui nous
sommes
quels sont les éléments de nous-mêmes
qu'il reste encore à travailler alors
aussi on apprend avec dans son axe à
être aligné à savoir respecter son
espace
on apprend à s'abandonner à l'inconnu on
apprend aussi à pas trop fusionner et
puis on apprend à marcher ensemble dans
le chaos de la milonga qui le bal le bal
de tango
alors je vais vous raconter une petite
anecdote cet été j'étais un festival de
tango en sicile et je prenais des cours
de tango avec un professeur qui
s'appelle joey col bat et donc pendant
le court il mime observe et s'approche
de moi il me pose la main sur le coeur
il me regarde droit dans les yeux et il
me dit valérie ch je ne te connais pas
mais on tombe servant j'ai l'impression
que tu as mal tu as peur de mal faire et
un peu mal aux pieds j'ai l'impression
que tu as peur de mal faire
mon professeur joe cole bata avait
décelé en moi ce syndrome de première de
la classe que je pensait pourtant avoir
réglé c'est incroyable comme le corps ne
l'ont jamais et puis il a poursuivi mais
dit valérie la danse est là pour te
libérer de thé conditionnements sociaux
familiaux professionnels un pose-toi
cherchent la liberté occupe ton espace
et n'oublie jamais ne fait jamais ce que
l'autre attend de toi
sa phrase ce précieux conseils mam a
rappelé une citation de rené char qui
m'a qui m'a suivi pendant tout mon
parcours que vous connaissez peut-être
impose ta chance serre ton bonheur et va
vers ton risque à te regarder ils
s'habitueront alors vous allez me dire
tout ça est bien jolie valérie ça a
l'air un peu bisounours ton truc mais
dont chemin là il ya quand même il ya
quand même des doutes il ya quand même
des peurs des obstacles et oui et oui
effectivement tout saut dans l'inconnu
vient réveiller nos démons intérieurs
vient réveiller des peurs archaïques
on rencontre des dragons comme on dit
dans le voyage du héros c'est une
métamorphose laventure d'être soi c'est
une mue il ya un moment donné où on a un
peu tout nu on est on est une perte de
repères il faut beaucoup d'amour en soi
et de et de confiance en soi pour pour
empaqueter pour embrasser notre ego et
notre petit saboteur intérieur qui nous
parle c'est cette petite voix qui ce
petit chacal qui nous dit tu y arriveras
jamais mais qui es tu pour te croire
différente des autres
pourquoi tu as toujours été une rêveuse
mais pourquoi tu rentres pas une bonne
fois pour toute dans le système
c'est pas grave
cette petite voix on peut l'accueillir
pour qu'elles transmute avec nous
soudain ne se cache toujours un trésor
c'est de loin l'étape la plus importante
car une de nos missions de vie c'est de
réussir à dépasser ce que nous
n'arrivons pas à faire comme parfois
tout simplement tard donné un proche qui
ne nous a pas soutenus
j'apprends à danser avec le chaos
et c'est en accueillant ma vulnérabilité
que la magie opère
la magie c'est aussi l'âme qui agit la
magie et donc je me retrouve un peu à mi
chemin entre ma puissance créatrice et
l'humilité la vulnérabilité face aux
événements
car effectivement j'ai appris dans ce
chemin qu'il fallait pas forcément
confondre la puissance et la toute
puissance je ne contrôle pas tout
alors dans ce chemin si je suis aligné
avec mon essence avec mon coeur je peux
être en mesure d'être en sécurité malgré
mes peurs je peux révéler ma puissance
je peux être dans l'abondance que je co
créé avec la vie et avec les autres
c'est peut-être comme ça qu'on apprend à
vivre ensemble parce que chaque rue et
chaque être humain est unique il est
unique et en même temps il est dans un
écosystème
on n'est pas séparée et c'est peut-être
comme ça qu'on arrive à passer du
pouvoir à la puissance de
l'individualisme à l'altruisme de lego
au coeur alors prenez votre plume et qu
écrivait le livre de votre vie parce que
si chacun de nous écrit sa légende
alors ensemble nous pourrons engendré
notre époque
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]